[Music]
all right now let's go ahead and start
with like we've talked about before on
every single Mortal Kombat character you
still have that flavor that's always
been there with characters and each
variation adds a little little touch
together so let's talk about the stuff
they share within exactly so common
mousse katana for probably most
signature move of the series or fan toss
there we go yeah that was really
effective the experts when you get a
double fan time and you can also do an
air version of that the air version is
one of her movies especially the combos
men's characters in the air for the one
absolutely that's kind of some classic
combo building right if you will you
also got your fam lift big combo starter
for fun oh yeah exactly you know
so you notice it's visually changed too
from like that I'm ki and there's
plastic fan lifts it actually looks more
like a tornado or technically later
style on that yes so that one's really
affected we're we are in oil storm storm
right now yeah that one actually has a
little bit different variation I will
get to that exactly but it's this one
will look a little bit different if you
see and like we talked with Spiro as
well when it comes to telling characters
apart this version has the glowing
stigma sticks in her hair and in smacks
lips yeah let's go through some other
sharers
she's got her she's got her oh we got
the color a little hello and there is
deceptively complex and really useful
because not only can you use it to dodge
projectiles when you're across the
screen or something but you can also
follow the hacks afterward right so you
can do things like jump in so I can do
like oh yeah exactly
[Music]
right there's a ton of possibilities so
it definitely can kind of trick the
opponent to thinking you're going to
land you don't laugh exactly exactly
so yeah a lot of utility in that one we
also have the yeah that move is very you
can burn a force I like to use it when I
get knocked down I like to use a kind of
weight to the back yeah sorry about that
so make sure everybody's saw his entry
yeah yeah so that's what happens step
just one of your contribution well yeah
I didn't have much I mean it should
something real quickly before I forget
all that concept art you just saw on the
stream if you look at nether realms
Twitter right now our community manager
Rico has put up a link to our tumblr
page so you can tear apart the stuff
even more yes though which we're excited
about
there's one more that's new a little new
we got a UH oh yeah the first life slot
yeah that looks really fast
yeah damage yeah it's a good all-around
like you know I'm finishing off our
juggle I left written space kind of at
mid screen it comes up so fast and so
yeah you can definitely like how to use
it Enders and such like this miss know
what I don't show off all your good
sorry I'm doing that but we also talked
you know those who don't play fighting
games a lot there's a there's a term we
use called [ __ ] yes and footsies is
kind of a way to always be sort of like
in the range where your best move is
right near them so this move for a curve
that this wood right there is great and
you're just at mid screen trying to fake
him out a little bit and improve
if you can predict where they're going
to be that's very dangerous because
we're trying to pack - on you usually
catch them they're a lot of utility for
that move now let's kind of go in this
bro storms differences yeah well summers
probably my favorite tree of which I
think it's funny because oh yeah
everyone was always like oh well they'll
just be one train everybody likes yeah
absolutely untrue because you were like
you like a roast or you like one of the
other one my favorite does a sense like
that because that's sort of how I like
to play although I've found matchups
where I like using a roast or exactly
it's I think the reason I like this one
so much is so much utility there's all
over her new losing this one and I have
a lot of really different functions and
so like it's the first one right regular
I can get about mid screen but if I'm
full screen ie exit yeah it was a full
screen and if I'm across the screen you
can be like fans your fans follow up on
combos all sorts of options that's been
super effective then you have the square
wave right yes yeah great for getting in
or also giving away I would say this
this version of her has me most airborne
boots she has the float she's got these
square wave in the air sauce a lot
accomplished that way I would say this
move really controls need controls
everything above you very very mean that
like she's very threatening jump
necessarily want to jump nightly she
also has this which Derek I believe I
think somebody picked a kind of don't
worry we'll see it later this this is
one of the best reflects I've ever seen
oh yeah you got you to hold it down so
if like you were talking earlier to me
about Cassie cage yeah Cassie cage has
oh yes gunshot there who has multiple
projectiles you don't just reflect one
you can reflect all three back
entertaining frankly and yeah it's any
character that is throwing multiple
attacks at you that are projectiles
right incredibly dangerous little across
the screen so this whole build could be
kind of effective as a zoning build
right if you're throwing different kinds
of conduct Isles out and bouncing stuff
back I like to use it as like an anti
zoning bills so if someone's trying to
just stay away from the end but build
jimang Bertie yeah period right yeah
I said I can use it variation this
variation to say no you can't just stay
away from to come at me and then I'm
controlling the game excellent yeah all
right let's move on to the next one and
as you can see in the corner we have
Goro we are not going to select him
today and I know that will disappoint
some people oh we at least put him on
screen for you we did there is his
character yeah
we'll be showing Goro we really soon
till I get I get so many tweets about
Goro hashtag punch wall hashtag yeah so
we won't things you need to do in a
fighting game but you just do them
together punch and walk yeah genius
let's go to through some out world
marketplace for this now this is what
this is the one that I actually as you
know for their Twitter if you've been
following me and Eric's beef I've been
doing a lot of practicing I'm gonna stay
late and practice I've been practicing a
lot with the assassin bear you mean
you've wasted a lot of time no I do my
work during the day and I stay late to
practice
okay alright so thank you so the
assassin now we got some eventually
pillar doesn't may have to be able it
occasionally and I will keep talking
yeah wow I know right so this one the
visual indicator is she has some black
again across her eyes and she has a mask
on my favorite visual nothing too vulgar
I love the look it's it sort of it's
dark very assassin a very assassin a
tough word to spell so this we add a
couple neat things she has a parry
mm-hmm which she can hold down yeah
that's not a projectile carry licker we
don't like to move it also like if you
if you'll do a low won't hit that easy
yeah exactly so you have to you have to
read your part really well you have to
kind of know what's coming but you can
predict that move is a great way to
limit someone who's just throwing stuff
out willy-nilly because you know there's
a lot of people out there who just love
push a lot of buttons give on top me
really quick yeah and you throw that out
there they're gonna start thinking twice
about exactly exactly
wake up option a couple things to each
let's show sharpen room we have sharpen
gives you additional standard actually I
found your fans on your own all of your
fan based attacks that's it it's time
based yes exactly it also has an
additional property must be showing next
movie right so I'm gonna do right now my
the thing that makes me really love the
assassin variations kind of all my
favorite moves in the game I'm gonna say
and like let's say you're there she can
run and hit him right in that so if they
if they with a move full screen you duck
something it's so fast that it can
really punish your opponents in that
what can I take out your eyes are open
every single time but in conjunction
with sharpens now when you do this you
don't need a bar of meter normally use I
should have shown that first yeah so
this is the meter inversion right this
yeah for expert while your blades are
sharpened you don't have that very good
for free and you can also do things like
as you finish a compote stead of netting
a damage you can actually do a sharpen
as your last one thing I love your dinos
after this I generally will get since
he's down for long I can you to sharpen
so you gotta really pick your time if it
takes time to do so that those are her
variations they really change up the way
she plays yeah this one can be very
rushed down anything you can use that
assassinate move to kind of punish
someone across the screen if it just
kind of some stupid up there you can
also probably at the most
so yeah if you're offensive you want to
get big damaging combos keep the
pressure up this Ridge and the GTX
version also has armor on it when it
first up to you if you're trying to get
through another one on the X absolutely
I think we got one more to show
yep showing off the swaggy combo saw
that swag now we've got a lot of tweets
real quick I just got to say something
we're doing something we don't we've
never really done before we're doing a
character
unrevealed yeah we're taking it there me
we're gonna tell you a character now
that will not show up in the game have
it okay say anything about that I mean I
mean did he just did so KB maybe not
Jade will not be in Mortal Kombat X we
have a moment of silence look at me they
were good there huh
so the mournful variation takes special
attacks from Jade and katana uses them
it's because you know she is she sad she
has lost her friend and now she's taking
up her mantle and uses her weapons to
kind of help when I live on yeah
so really Jade spirits in the game yeah
and right here in the heart right my
heart so maybe I didn't be revealed her
at all yeah I mean but she dumped me
that's how you started yeah that's now
yeah so here she has some J desk moves
now yeah we talked about the fan sir
yeah exactly we said she had some
projectile variations this one uses the
blade and you can throw that straight
you can also tilt the move up and down
right and get hit the targets above
so you can throw that logo for the high
but you can also do an airborne version
as well so you can kind of you control
space a little bit differently you don't
have this much more bottle control that
you control the room a significant
portion of the screen with carefully
right you also have a very effective
version of that in the needlework
version that is active for a really long
time they Bend right back to you exactly
so far away you can get combos when they
will be closer if you have to deal with
that for a long time it's on the screen
for a long time so great way to control
space and keep a person locked down
right basically that a lot of things
property is its gene for men right so if
you were familiar with programming
canine there's not a lot of differences
here yeah and the the air version of
that also has the loop learning effect
[Music]
yeah I mean right now just do a trick
here not fun but I'm gonna help city hit
- yeah left em enough I'm not very good
at that here yeah you learned that I'm
not either
we also have we have this yeah that the
grab from her stepping once I called a
grandson want to show off everything on
your batons even the x-ray my dad's new
everybody I mean I gotta around you so
that's a really good another big combo
in dirt and also yeah yeah the new burn
breathing that your likes your damage
she also have the shadow kick here which
is down so yeah you pressure up now so
if you're if you're a fan of Jaden
someplace
again that's what you like okay there we
go so that is those are all the sort of
variations of katana you'll be seeing
them a little bit later because Derrick
I have our battle coming very soon I'm
excited before then though we'd like to
go